but helpful advice with Bobby at kilala
the answer to this question is probably
going to fall more in kalila given our
background as a nurse but I'm interested
to hear Bobby side too given the time he
spent with her in hospitals I've been in
intensive care nurse for just under two
years now and absolutely loved my
parents and their families but I have a
tendency to let patient family members
walk all over me because I'm still very
new to nursing and feel like I need to
please everyone how should I make it
known that while I'm here to help my
patient have been patient have the best
chance of surviving a critical illness
or trauma as well as help the family
cope that the hospital is not a hotel
I'm I'm not I'm more than a bellboy so I
guess that's pretty frustrating because
a lot of my friends who graduated me who
were working her in their second year of
Nursing some of them are ICU nurses who
are very very good nurses very bright
girls they have the exact same question
you know I have I I even have a girl
friend of mine who she's a white girl a
blonde girl from Orange County she's a
very very bright girl very astute
probably one of the smartest girls that
came out of my nursing program but
because of the demographics of Long
Beach Memorial she gets hated on a lot
kind of like what we do to you George
where it's like the families who either
if they're like you know the for
instance she gave me an example of let's
say for instance that an
african-american family who completely
just were like oh like what does that
white girl what does that little white
girl know you know she's doing her
baskets in and you know it's an it's an
intense setting right it's a one-on-one
one nurse that sometimes they have two
patients but you got tubes coming out
like everything every every five minutes
matters then when you're an intensive
care nurse it is very very like
high-stress job and I think that it's
normal because she is a new nurse
you just have to grit and bear that's
part of the process I think I don't have
an answer for you other than I have an
answer you're going to figure it out I
have an answer you want to hear it yeah
the last thing we went to the hospital
kalila and I write she had to get a
nurse had to come in and do some tests
on her right should it hook something up
and what Dad do something I know what it
is but I was in the way
right and she just sat there patiently
and I said to her I'm so sorry I know
I'm in your way I'll move because I I'm
her boyfriend but you they have to do a
job yeah okay and if I'm in the way of
that job then you tell me I'm in the
[ __ ] way all right because I know
that you guys are professionals and I
you know I if I knew what had a nurse
she wouldn't have to come to the
hospital I had the equipment at home but
I'm not a profession so I guess you're
right it is good to stand firm and stand
your ground and if people are not
respecting the space of healing you
should let them know like hey this isn't
conducive to me working doing what I
need to do for your family member if you
can exit while I do this you know it's
it's obviously their right to be there
but if it's getting in the way of what
you need to do you should you have the
right to verbalize that but when my dad
was in the hospital and my brother and I
came I think was like a year ago and my
mom was at the hospital and we showed up
during the day and my mom cause they
didn't they didn't remember and my
brother and I just went because the
reason why they did that was because
here they see an immigrant mother who
barely speaks in speaks English but you
know in front of America she gets
nervous right and so she just kind of
ran over her yeah so then I come up with
the kalila and my brother and I and my
brother I don't know if you know but
he's cute but when he gets angry he's a
snapperhead range so we're both like
going what the you know I mean we're
angry right and then they were like oh
no we you know sorry you know there must
have been like you know miscommunication
right just do your [ __ ] job - yeah
but do your job and I will let you do
your job I'll tell you what though yes
there are a lot of reckless nurses that
are usually in the Med surg floor or
like
a lesser like acuity floor but she's an
ICU nurse intensive care it like I said
it's one on one the doctor will probably
show up for five minutes to do an
assessment but everything falls on this
nurse every tiny bit of change if if the
patient B compensates it's on her it's
on her all of it then they start
decomposing no decompensate means like
your your blood pressure or something
out your heart rate you know they just
say give it something else then but
they're not doing well yeah yeah but her
job is a very very tough job it's an
honorable job and if the family is
getting in the way of your work you
should say it diplomatically nicely and
say this is what I have to do like get
out of my way however nicely you can put
that honorable isn't even the work it's
your your job is probably one of the
most important jobs at the [ __ ]
hospice Peschel e at this level yeah and
it's like you yeah you know L
praise be like surgeries and and those
kind of things are left to the surgeon
but everything around that you're very
important and I've noticed that from my
dad's sickness and from your sickness
and I already you know I know that you
know she's a nurse my girlfriend and
also she I mean but you went to school
you know and oh my god disco do you know
what just happened oh my god a TD child
that was such a quick thing I just
happened
[Music]